everybody's Shawn here at Gamescom 2014
I've got bowl from paradox development
studio who is here to show us room
master for the very first time well tell
us what we're seeing here yeah we're
about to enter a world of Norse
mythology and it's a tactical RPG it's
actually our studio's first RPG ever
even though Crusader Kings 2 did have
elements of RPG and it's also our first
tactical battle anyway also our first
adventure into the unknown it's a lot of
first
yeah we're living history for mythology
actually so it's gonna be an interesting
ride so what you see here first is that
you select the race and there are six or
eight different races to choose from and
they all share worlds in some aspects so
they're actually for starting worlds but
we're gonna go with humans in Midgard
okay so we have three classes but you
can only see two one is scout that is a
ranged hero we have a circle that is not
a combat and then we also have the room
master that is focused on magic but each
race only have two classes so you sort
of have to pick and choose so what do
you want oh you know as much as I like
the beard on that Berserker let's go
with skull okay it's kind of is so and
now we can just choose the banner and
you have a name preference so should we
go in everybody I'm a good randomized
name
yeah let's randomize it so singing yeah
I like normal nice sounds like you
already picked side so what happens now
is that every single world when this
game is
lately randomized every time we play so
it's a new venture every time this is a
fairly early alpha build so of course it
not it's not as randomized and we're
gonna be and but as you can see we're
complete fans of old-school RPGs and
it's a bit of top-down and the quests in
this game is randomized as well so we
can just have a quick chat with Vollmer
here the story goes that he found us in
the woods and we were muttering about
ambition and he can't really help us
with that but he gives us a welcome back
and says like well go on you're not my
problem yeah so we actually got a feeble
bowler arrangement so we can just jump
in and equip that and for RPG fans you
know you can see the health the armor
the amount of damage and so on you can
see the inventory that is pretty empty
if you we go in there and we have
personal trades but we'll delve into
that later so let's jump out and we're
on our way and the only thing we know is
we need to find out more about this
mission we had okay so the game is a lot
about exploration and it's about
storytelling and it's about battles so
here comes the battle this is an easy
one or fairly simple one just to learn
you the ropes and what you see here is
the victory condition its defeat Lars
bullies so we're gonna do that and
I suspect that Sara loves her abilities
she's gonna try and take them out
immediately with an ability and it was
the Eagle on shot so you got a pretty
good a few lone survivors there yeah you
can see the blinking that's the focus
points that we spend on the ability and
Adam again yeah going for the kill
strike early yeah so no now we're
actually getting our first unit so we're
gonna go with ax men since were arranged
and we got a bit of experience and
venture into the unknown
Oh level to health always right
so yeah the storytelling is very much
inspired by old-school RPGs we have a
lot of branching paths and character
development but the battles are more
inspired by such games as Heroes of
Might and Magic mm-hmm
but since we are a strategy stadium you
know the strategy elements will be it
will be a lot more tactical we can
recruit a bit of troops here so we'll
just pick a few and not give it that
much thought but they have special
abilities and everything it's how I play
a video game there are squads so you can
gather units and different squads and
they can basically help each other out
you're in battle you can spread them out
all over you know this is the battle
setup right basically so you can spread
them out but they do have a better place
that you know help each other out so it
would be kind of stupid
so yeah for example shield-wall or a
passive so all friendly units nearby
against +20 depends and they also have
abilities that you can develop what more
yeah so the personality trait system if
we go and talk to school they were here
she's actually a fake goddess but we
don't know this at this point of the
game but she wants to know who you are
so we're gonna choose one of the you
know already sets this is just to give
you an idea so either we're our true at
heart careful and resource close but not
afraid to threaten those who deserve it
or Burt I'm not a coward both words come
easy to me and I'm a liar bribe so what
do you do
mmm let's see you know I feel like it's
a short demo we don't have to live with
the consequences
let's pick Howard or actually not
accounting not account no but you may
not yeah main life no you know who you
are so she would guide you for there
alone your path but she is threatening
you you know um that you know your needs
search for the velvet but she will soon
die and you have challenges in your way
run so one you actually again here are
the trades so you gain a bit of know it
not a bit of you gain extravagant you
gained elusive manipulative and brave
okay so that's your current hero that's
and what happens personality traits is
that you unlock personality traits and
then you get consequences and that's new
answers new options new quests actually
and new rewards based on your traits
okay and those will go like back and
forth do probably do they change a lot
early on and then just less and less as
the game goes on it's probably gonna be
about the same but it's not gonna be
this quick right now it's gonna be small
changes towards so the thing is that as
long as you really role play this game
and that I mean almost in a you know
in your mind you need to set like what
kind of hair do I want to play and that
will sort of direct you into you know
shaping your path if you play to safe or
you know you're - I'm consistent in your
choices you're gonna have less in the
game to be frank but it's not just you
know two choices it's eight so it's
quite unlikely that you don't get at
least one trade order um so yeah we can
talk to an embassy maybe if you find
someone like me I don't know this is
just random most of them actually talk
about Quest or what's going on and well
this one is just for fun so the thing is
like with reoccurring embassies they're
supposed to be friends you know almost
and they may take you further along the
main story of the game but yeah okay so
do you want a couple of coins or you
won't love me no magic what you resist
let's say love mean and magic okay then
you gain a bit of brave there so let's
go and assist him at the rune stone and
this is the overview map we haven't
discovered anything there are a lot of
quests hidden throughout the world but
they're not visible until you actually
accepted them okay so this is a larger
battlefield but still like we have a lot
of different but this is a bit more
strategically because you need to think
a bit tactical because that terrain in
our game matter mm-hmm so high ground
more damage and if the enemies beneath
you and vice versa
you have your abilities your units have
abilities as well but you need to be
careful since you only have limited
focus points and you can see the turns
in the side you can also see health 18
of 18 505 in Armour and 0 16 there are
16 is actually discipline so you inflict
you can take both physical damage and
terror damage in your enemy
once you click enough terror to break
their discipline they will run for it
okay the same goes for you you know they
don't flee the battlefield they speed to
different parts of the battlefield
okay away and then they stand there and
try and rally and you know gather
strength
what is pretty cool about our battles is
that we can have multiple wind
collisions and defeat collisions mm-hmm
so for example here we have to defeat
conditions no we have wind condition
defeat all enemies the defeat condition
unless were our soft skill is if Corrin
gets killed because the golf the undead
girlfriends join us
she's unit and if that Ghost take her
out then we lost the battle so we'll see
here how it goes
yeah she killed them so she's actually
says take those dawn runes away from him
and keep them to yourself and she says
that you know he's the scowls not a
warrior and he's so silly if I were
alive I would slap some sense into it so
well you asked him to let go your sweet
memory or make sure Tommy is a very
single man Musa very salient okay - so
we can experience a thing is yeah the
unit's only gain experience from what
they do the hero gains experience both
from battles and quests okay so do you
generally yes can just take this only
sure Amy so yeah we tell them Karma's
here so did she have any words for me so
stop trying to bring her back and for
olden say go on with your life or she'd
slap some sense into you silly man
that's basically what you said you're
gonna stick with it or you're gonna lie
and say she misses your sweet song okay
let's stick with it stick with it yes
that's my car so what a woman so he
actually says like take these rooms away
from me she's right you know I'll hurt
myself so
now
and yeah it's not probably gonna
progress this fast but you know you get
idea of this and we got a bit of praise
because we were honest a mover brave we
told them the truth straight to his face
yeah a second ago about the unit's yeah
is it you generally like is it possible
to pick some up early on and level them
up and train that throughout the whole
game or do you kind of constantly shed
units to pick up no you can absolutely
train the units it's sort of a choice
you have to make because the the further
along you go the better units will
probably be available but you can also
level up if you go to the battle master
in the city the thing is that they
really need to earn their XP themselves
if you kill all the bodies they're not
getting any use any XP okay they only
get XP for their actions so this is the
basics for the training ground where you
can see what it costs to level up you
can see the small arrows that says what
to level up
with the world thing you said in the
world is randomly generated
there's I'd imagine they're still kind
of a logic that determines which cities
you run in first run into first yes
right now this is a very limited build
sense about fun you know previous so we
have made the world a lot smaller as
well and there are key points where that
you know you will pass that are fairly
linear but the idea is that with
personality traits even have new options
to pass those points okay so either
battle the moment she ran into battle
home spider is gonna die but you know in
other situations you might be able to
talk your way through make the monster
or you leave or even join your army I
don't think you can get the spider in
your army but you know yeah that's a big
spider
how frequent are these kind of non-human
battles well like most I mean most
battles in mid Gord I guess is against
you know maybe bears wolves trolls
spider it's very varied and also humans
of course right but I mean it's so sort
of the tents on what world as well but
what's around what something those lands
yeah I mean when you retell him which is
the domain of the goddess hell you know
you can imagine there's pretty much
undead but there will be different kinds
when that if I move so that was a
critical hit we just saw there and it's
five percent chance and then you do
double the damage or double the bonus
for the ability mm-hmm they sort of
flashes for your eyes you can see their
shield wall is because the user is
actually managing to take the spider
down big one yeah the tiny is still
living but yeah it is a lot of battle
focus and we really wanted to have them
in the battles but we also wanted to
make them pretty easy to grasp okay so
actually if you kill the spider there
may be a quest that makes wild animals
eat from the body and you know spread
the disease throughout the lands if you
don't kill the spider this will long
happen but even if you kill the spider
it might not happen you know Richard so
here's the battle about the world tell
us about our mission in life vanish so
she actually sent us this mission and
she tells us them the god boulder has
been killed and this is made by Loki
because he wants to trigger Ragnarok in
the end of the world he does this
because he believes this is a good thing
he plays the world is a horrible place
he needs to change
well the Thor thinks this is a very nice
place and it should remain as it is you
know and that's just gonna cause him
suffering and pain mm-hmm so she
basically guides us that we need to find
Muspelheim to go and find the Horn of
Minnie these portals are usually locked
this is a fairly late part of the game
we just you know made a very small build
solution [ __ ] so this would be maybe
level 25 or something okay and like in
do you have any estimate in terms of
hours how long that usually yeah we're
oh I would say maybe 25 and we're aiming
at 40-plus you know for the game but we
also wanted to be repayable
and what happens is actually before we
entered is that you will be able to
travel between the for starting runs in
your own choice you know whether the
quest brings you there or where you want
to start but most flame is a point where
you reach when you reach further than
right so but now we're gonna go to
Mustang
I mean York and I miss this place of IC
and you know frosting I was supposed a
frosted Giants but that is didn't sound
right
but yeah and everything is like based on
real Norse mythology we have gods
roaming the world as be occurring
empathy Odin is the old bugger trickster
that he's running around all over the
place
Freya the war goddess is there right up
and so yeah we're not gonna keep him so
I I think this is your cue for you know
asking any questions you want about this
why don't we go ahead and end with the
standard closer can you tell us you know
when you guys are hoping to have it
finished and obviously we're seeing it
played on a DualShock 4 controller right
now yeah it's running on a PC clarify
the platforms okay
so it was just announced at the Sony
press conference so we're releasing it
for PlayStation 4 ok for PC Mac and
Linux and we're gonna do a simultaneous
release if all goes well and it's for
the first half of 2015 all right thank
you very much yeah thank you